Rigby maker that she's with us know hi
Beth what do you think well I was in the
hall and um it went down really well in
there there was obviously that
disruption with the protesters the green
freeze process that was quite unpleasant
and a bit ugly but actually the Prime
Minister picked up with that jibe about
the anti-growth Coalition which she
picked up in her speech and after that
the crowd almost uh roused more towards
her so in terms of the reception in the
room it was a good job for Liz truss but
there was more than that in that speech
and that she was trying to talk not just
to the room but beyond that room and
what she was trying to do there was the
back story and really I think what she
was trying to show voters was that she
understood them and she was an ordinary
person if you like she made a virtue of
the fact that she was the only the first
Prime Minister she said to have gone to
a comprehensive school she talked is
that right well Gordon Brown went to a
state school there's some discussion
about whether it's a comprehensive or a
selective School labor told me it's a
comprehensive now they're not sure so
once I know I'll let you know but she
said she was the first to go to a
comprehensive school and then she talked
about uh being a young woman being
different from other people facing
barriers so she was really trying to
paint herself as on the side of working
people and then she painted labor as a
party of the north London Elite which
she like likes to do and and also the
media so she she sort of found some
attack lines there and then to her party
she talked about the fact that it was
difficult that there would be more
turmoil when there was change and I
think the message to the back benches
was I am plowing on and that was the
message to them I think the question
about this speech and whole conference
is does she come out of that whole
stronger or weaker now in the moment
they the expectations were low and she
delivered Her speech but the problems
that she walks out to are unchanged and
are not going to go away and when you
think about sorry no no no I was gonna
say when you think about some of the
problems piling up
the issue with the back benches the new
attack Lyle battle line over uh lifting
benefits by inflation not earnings it
seems that she would may be minded to
lift them by earnings that would be a
real terms benefit cut because of course
inflation's running much I do just want
to give people a flash photography
warning here just in case people are
watching at home and it might cause them
an issue you were saying she's walking
out there yeah um
in terms of that battle line between her
and her back benches I mean two cabinet
ministers told me last night that they
were also in favor of it Rising with
inflation and what's more I was told uh
that the back bench chair so growing
Brady had made it clear to the Prime
Minister that MPS would not support an
up racing violence so this is a new
Battlefront and my point if if given
that policy detail is really to say the
bigger picture here is that this is a
prime minister that says change is
difficult I'm focused on growth I am
going to deliver for the economy but in
terms of what she can practically do as
a prime minister if she doesn't have the
authority to Corral her back benches is
unclear so she might be quite
constrained in what she can do and so
for all the rhetoric in that Hall what
she actually does coming out of it and
how effective she can be as a prime
minister is really in doubt